les plus forts de la cérémonie est ce
que vous avez regardé jean marc et des
bas alors nous on était en tournée j'ai
regardé ça sur mon téléphone j'ai fou ap
pars pars par l'émission c'était
magnifique genre qui a eu aucune fausse
note je trouve c'est vrai très sobre est
génial et donc du coup on a tous regardé
mais comme ça complètement hypnotisés
par les chansons qu on entendait les
gens criaient durant nos tizi je suis
assez d'accord exilés pas c'est pas
facile et je voulais vraiment rajouter
c'est pas facile parce que nous on est
des humoristes et en ce moment il se
passe tellement de choses c'est pas
facile encore de rigoler sur scène avec
tout ce qui se passe et j'ai un g1
personnages auront spectacle s'appelle
jacquier qui est fan de johnny johnny et
ça a été très compliqué pour moi
mercredi de faire ce sketch parce que
j'ai senti dans la salle que on n'avait
pas le droit de rigoler ce soir là et
j'ai quand même tenu à faire le sketch
et et j'ai senti ouais j'ai senti les
applaudissements après parce que j'ai
rajouté une petite phrase dans le sketch
qui accable qui a je pense fait réagir
le public et les applaudissements
derrière était surréaliste je n'ai
jamais entendu des applaudissements
vraiment le public voilà était derrière
johnny quoi quels jeux vous sont super
et mieux school avait connu johnny parce
que les pas du tout pas devait comme non
voilà vous étiez en fait j'ai commencé
ce métier je me suis dit un jour je
serai connu et je rencontrerai à johnny
et j'ai pas eu le temps
voilà j'ai plein d'amis en commun qui
m'ont envoyé des textos mercredi et
samedi qui m'ont dit johnny aurait adoré
jacky voilà et ça m'a vraiment touché
comme en bas ça